un autre à qui on a demandé d'aller
faire un petit test technique s'est
porté volontaire avait des vides à
manger
c'est vrai que nos téléspectateurs
étaient nombreux à nous envoyer des
petits mots en nous disant bombe à 20
ans assez facile à peu près d'avers
demain 30 ans ça commence à être un
petit peu compliqué et puis quand on
arrive à la cinquantaine là c'est pour
perdre le petit bijou c'est c'est
vraiment difficile
que faire que faire évidemment
jean-michel seront posés là et a dit je
vais vous écrivez testé je peux dire une
petite précaution éloignez les enfants
tout les jeux j'ai surtout fait parce
que je retrouve tellement dégueulasse
amiens 5e ch
sickology qu'est qu'on se voit comme ça
on se dit c'est pas ça peut plus durer
oui donc ça va participer au fait que je
fais d'accord mais c'est vrai que la
télé ça aide parfois d'après vous avez
testé de nouvelles techniques pour
regarder vous nous expliquer après tu as
honte bons valérie c'est ça rigole plus
on y est
voilà opération anti graisse anti bidon
opération abdou opération spartacus pour
les vacances dans trois mois c'est l'été
y a plus on peut plus rigoler maintenant
j b les gaufres et bien bienvenue bon
super ravie de vous accueillir
bah moi aussi j'espère que vous allez me
transformer attention déchets pas on
n'est pas mais en tout cas faire en
sorte que des soyez content cet été ça
vous a normalement je pense que mon
choix en fonction se former parce qu'on
s'approche alors que le petit programme
sympa on commence par le médecin et si
tout se passe bien on a prévu deux
traitements différents aujourd'hui qu'on
va combiner ensemble nous accompagne
alors pourquoi se voit ton aujourd'hui
pour le vendre pour le monde
qu'est-ce qui se passe le pneu petite
surprise pour moi c'est l'été après le
choc nous avons et qui fait ou pas on y
va
bon alors c'est ça qui est gênant là je
pense qu'effectivement on va passer avec
la grande bulle jedox bus d'environ à
deux techniques pour vous en faites vous
allez avoir une première technique qui
va enlever l'excès de graisse ça dure
une heure on va aspirer la zone va
obtenir ce qu'on appelle une petite zone
je les ai effectivement c'est un pain de
glace on va masser pendant deux minutes
là ces deux minutes de bonheur pour le
patient
ça c'est pas partie la plus agréable du
process mais bon c'est quand même
supportable
on sent bien que c'est
la glace dans le ventre on entend
d'autres cassés les glaçons et où on est
votre pied à me faire mal non la
deuxième technique il va aller faire
travailler votre muscle c'est un travail
comme en salle mais multiplié par mille
c'est comme si vous faisiez 20 séances
d'abdos la séance dure une demi-heure
vous allez avoir donc les de paddle qui
sont posées sur votre vos abdominaux et
vous allez le sentir il faut quatre
séances ça passe par la vague des bons
temps c'est parce que ça fait du bien
voilà écoute la journée s'est très bien
passé quelques petits moments à vous ça
picote mais le reste la journée c'est le
top
on est super sympa alors justement
justement d'abord est-ce que vous avez
mal franchement l'effet de la glace ça
fait un peu mal parce que déjà on aspire
la glace pour pas bien mais le musc on
la spire avant de la congeler r - c'est
sur de petites bouilles et après on a le
ventoux durée a pris le mas encore la
glace qui est congelé fall avant de la
grèce qui est congelé lci minutes de
trois mois ce monde on shoote à calais
fait maintenant on voyait pas encore la
différence non mais dans deux mois dans
trois mois on pressent que vous avez
vous compté continue à le faire
non mais une fois mais il faut que la
grèce ou éliminé naturellement justement
alors c'est quoi cette c'est quoi c'est
de la cryothérapie c'est la cryolipolyse
c'est celle de la cryothérapie ça veut
dire qu'on va combler la grèce en fait
la cellule de grèce est très sensible au
froid et donc une fois qu'elle va être
congelés elle se détruit assez
rapidement après on rajoute des
mouvements pour faire bouger le muscle
améliorer la circulation
donc ça marche pas si mal que ça
benjamin il était très envieux mais
pourquoi ne pas envoyer moi je moi je
fais le musculeux pas deuxième la
deuxième c'est très efficace
c'est comme si vous avez une énorme
séance de sport 2000 ces vingt mille
push-ups family
on fait en 30 minutes et là vous avez un
corps de rêve pas encore mais j'y
travaille j'y vais j'y vois là s'est
dessiné la s'est dessinée ou pas pas
encore mais moi j'ai pas de chance j'ai
pas fait de sport pendant quatre mois à
cause de mon accident donc j'ai fait ça
pour ça me permet de faire plus de sport
et plus rapidement boxer ça c'est pas du
bureau c'est bien c'est vrai bien sûr le
mgk savez en fureur en américain c'est
le carton absolu ça c'est une vraie
musculature c'est pas les petites
ceintures combi et c'est assez dingue ou
bleu puissant donc ça permet de faire du
sport et a dû aussi bien pour les
garçons que pour les chats bah oui vous
aussi vous le faites dans les villes
soient les avez un abonnement
suivent le ventre et les fesses mais
vous allez faire quoi avec ça mais on a
toujours besoin moi j'ai de la cellulite
génial c'est à dire que depuis le début
que cette édition on apprend qu'elle
contrôle de sa nourriture qu'elle fait
du sport c'est vrai que j'ai un
métabolisme franchement merci la vie
merci merci est-ce que c'est voir ça au
niveau du melon
la chambre se doit donner un lien
combien toutes ces séances est cher 500
euros environ la séance l'argent pour
faire 3 ou 4 et se passer de quelques
jours pour que ce soit vraiment efficace
est ce que l'âme la machine coûte que
coûte expliqué